Alice: : 那就是别外的价钱我跟你说
Alice: That's an extra charge, I'm telling you.
Alice: 怎么 你不应该邀请我一下吗
Alice: What? Aren't you going to invite me?
Jake: 呃你现在可以对我换掉的
Jake: Uh, you can swap with me now.
Jake: 在哪充电了
Jake: Where's the charging?
其他人: 换掉我放你放你
Others: Swap with me, I'll let you.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Alice: 我去你家玩了
Alice: I went to your house to hang out.
Alice: 你给我准备好床
Alice: You better have a bed ready for me.
Alice: 我要我要
Alice: I want, I want.
Alice: 新的拖鞋 床单被罩
Alice: New slippers, bed sheets, and covers.
Alice: 可以用你的
Alice: Can I use yours?
Alice: 床也要躺你的
Alice: I also want to lie on your bed.
Tasha: : 到你这个频率每周出去换个景点
Alice: 我已经逛完了差不多
Alice: I've almost seen everything.
Alice: 完蛋了差你家没去了
Alice: Oh no, I haven't been to your house yet.
Alice: 你能不能给我唱一首北京欢迎你
Alice: Can you sing "Beijing Welcomes You" for me?
Alice: 就是我家大门常打开是吧
Alice: Like "My door is always open", right?
Alice: 我都不知道你家门在哪开
Alice: I don't even know where your door opens.
其他人：: 不知道就好
Alice: 你真的不邀请我去你家玩吗
Alice: Are you really not inviting me to your house?
Katrina:  邀请你去我有玩儿不给你增添
Katrina: If I invite you, I won't add any fun.
Alice: 对呀又可以
Alice: Yeah, and it can be.
Shure:  花瓶下的
Shure: Under the vase.
Katrina:  啊花瓶下的
Katrina: Ah, under the vase.
其他人： 一楼的么
Others: On the first floor?
Katrina:  可能被他们女生找到了
Katrina: Maybe the girls found it.
其他人：: 给你们仨都带走咋地
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈够明显了
Katrina: Hahaha, that's obvious enough.
其他人：: 原来原来
Katrina:  二楼遥控器呢
Katrina: Where's the remote on the second floor?
Jake:: 恩
其他人： 不是你麦克吗
Others: Isn't it your mic?
其他人：这是麦克pro吗
Others: Is this a MacBook Pro?
其他人：:我怎么感觉看着不像pro
其他人： 这个看起来没有很
Others: This doesn't look very...
其他人：哎等一下如果我想把电脑之前的导出来我需要
Others: Hey, wait a minute, if I want to export my previous computer data, do I need...
Jake: 来我要教 你了
Jake: Come, I'll teach you.
Shure:  哎招呼我吧
Shure: Hey, call me over.
Jake: 哎等一下我可能还要加两个
Jake: Wait a minute, I might need to add two more.
Shure:  我叫修硕的MacBook Pro
Shure: My name is Shure, and this is my MacBook Pro.
Katrina:  看见遥控器了吗
Katrina: Have you seen the remote?
Shure:  没有
Shure: No.
Katrina:  我房间里没有呀
Katrina: It's not in my room.
Shure:  你笑什么
Shure: Why are you laughing?
Katrina:  没有我就是   的声音
Katrina: I'm not, it's just... the sound.
Alice: 我知道
Alice: I know.
其他人：: 我忘了
Shure: : 我考 这个
其他人：:快还不一样
Shure: : 不是啊
其他人：: 这个肯定不行这个肯定不行
Shure: 昨天谁问 应该喂
Shure: Who asked yesterday? Should feed...
其他人：: 那有办法能导出来吗
Shure:  什么呀
Shure: What?
其他人：: 直接导出来
Shure: 可以
Shure: Sure.
Shure:  点那个edit
Shure: Click on "edit".
Shure:  然后拿上这个虾仁
Shure: Then pick up these shrimp.
Shure:  也不是rose 是哪呢
Shure: It's not rose, so where is it?
Shure:  Settings
Shure: Settings.
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Shure:  对这是URL
Shure: Yes, this is the URL.
Shure:  然后复制暂停回去就可以
Shure: Then copy, pause, and go back.
Shure:  哎
Shure: Oh.
其他人：哦明白
Others: Oh, got it.
其他人：厉害  让我去试一试
Others: Awesome, let me try it.
Katrina:  那个他好像在弹吉他可以吗
Katrina: He's playing the guitar, is that okay?
Shure:  啊
Shure: Huh?
Katrina: 他可以弹你的吉他吗
Katrina: Can he play your guitar?
Shure:  他可以他可以
Shure: He can, he can.
Shure:  我帮你拿出一瓶苏打水
Shure: I'll get you a bottle of soda.
Katrina:  几点了
Katrina: What time is it?
Shure:  哈3点 15
Shure: Ha, 3:15.
Katrina:   时间过了
Katrina: Time's up.
Jake:哦人齐了吗
Jake: Oh, is everyone here?
Shure:  我刚刚拿一瓶苏打水放这里
Shure: I just put a bottle of soda here.
Katrina:  但是人没齐
Katrina: But not everyone is here.
Jake: 差谁点一下吧
Jake: Who's missing? Let's check.
Katrina:  Lucia的朋友来了吗
Katrina: Has Lucia's friend arrived?
Katrina:  没来吧
Katrina: No, right?
Jake: 点一下 每个人看看
Jake: Click and let everyone see.
Jake: Lucia Lucia在哪
Jake: Lucia, where's Lucia?
Katrina:  Lucia在一楼
Katrina: Lucia is on the first floor.
Katrina:  烧那个东西
Katrina: Doing that burning thing.
其他人：只有那个啊叫什么
Others: That's the only one, what's it called...
Katrina:  我要拿个奶酪
Katrina: I need to get some cheese.
Jake: 我问问去
Jake: I'll go ask.
Jake: 你去接
Jake: You go pick her up.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Katrina:  我刚接找了半天我天啊
Katrina: I just picked her up, looked for so long, my gosh.
Shure:  度假来着
Shure: On vacation.
Shure:  下来了就行就行
Shure: It's fine as long as she comes down.
其他人：  还有PPT吗
Others: Is there still a PPT?
Shure:  yes 我看到 咱们第一项不是PPT吗
Shure: Yes, I saw it, isn't the first item a PPT?
Jake: 对是PPT
Jake: Yes, it's a PPT.
Shure:  啊对 PPT不就是introduction吗
Shure: Oh right, PPT is just the introduction, right?
Katrina:  我以为introduction是他们嘛
Katrina: I thought the introduction was theirs.
Shure:  啊不是
Shure: Oh no.
其他人:哎还有奶酪包
Others: Oh, there's still cheese bread.
Katrina:  最后一个
Katrina: The last one.
Shure:  拿完放这 摆摆摆摆
Shure: After you take it, put it here, arrange it.
Jake: 摆摆摆摆  摆一排
Jake: Arrange it, arrange it, line them up.
Shure:   摆开摆
Shure: Spread them out.
Jake: 摆摆摆快摆
Jake: Arrange them quickly.
Jake: 别他妈坐着
Jake: Don't just sit there.
刘婷: 呃我有一个朋友可能会来
Liu Ting: Uh, I have a friend who might come.
Alice: 给
Alice: Here.
刘婷: 对
Liu Ting: Right.
Katrina:  然后还有我们店店子的地还挺好
Katrina: And then, our store's location is pretty good.
Alice: 给你个原味的
Alice: Here's a plain one for you.
Jake: 我们现在
Jake: We are now...
其他人：这差不多应该算齐了
Others: This should be almost everything.
Jake: 我们现在算齐了
Jake: We are now complete.
其他人： 有可能会到
Others: She might come.
其他人：对她有可能来
Others: Yeah, she might come.
Jake: 哦这么 呵呵呵
Jake: Oh, really? Haha.
Jake:  好嘞好的没关系
Jake: Alright, that's fine.
Jake: 那我们就
Jake: Then we'll...
其他人：就因为理论上说就是就是
Others: Because theoretically, just...
刘婷: 其他人：
Liu Ting: Others:...
其他人：  他今天应该会就是有时间应该会过来
Other: He should have time to come over today.
其他人：不过他现在没跟我说
Other: But he hasn't told me yet.
Jake: 好没关系
Jake: Alright, no problem.
其他人：刘婷: 那个妹子的话
Other (Liu Ting): About that girl...
其他人：他因为太远了就不太方便
Other: It's a bit inconvenient for her because it's too far.
其他人： 如果他来的话就要来
Other: If she comes, it'll be for about two hours.
其他人： 两个小时左右然后回去还得回
Other: Then she has to go back.
其他人： 两个小时
Other: Two hours.
其他人：啊一会儿你们把这些凳子要不都搬上去
Other: Ah, can you guys move these chairs upstairs?
Jake: 哎你你来搬
Jake: 哈哈哈OK不是我们
Jake: Hahaha, OK, not us.
Jake: 我我们开开个场吧要不 往后摆 然后
Jake: How about we start with an opening? Move them back, and then...
其他人：还是让他们坐比如坐垫子上
Other: Or let them sit on cushions.
Jake: 我想一想
Jake: Let me think.
Jake: 哎我想一想
Jake: Hey, let me think.
Jake: 这边可能
Jake: Maybe over here...
Katrina:  还可以在这贴两个
Katrina: We can stick a couple here.
Jake: 这我们得都上去
Jake: We need to go up.
Jake: 那这个我们能上去搞
Jake: Can we do it?
Jake: 吗对
Jake: Yes.
Alice: 这个快这个快
Alice: This one, quickly.
其他人：要不搞完再上去
Other: Or finish this and then go up.
Jake:对 要不这一波
Jake: Yeah, or this round...
Jake: 这这这一波
Jake: This round...
Jake: 这波搞完
Jake: Finish this round.
Jake: 我上去
Jake: I'll go up.
Jake: 好行
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 上去就介绍一下
Jake: Go up and do an introduction.
Jake: 然后开场
Jake: Then the opening.
Jake: 呃到处每个房间走一走
Jake: Uh, walk around each room.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah.
Jake: 装饰完了吗
Jake: Is it decorated?
Katrina:  没有
Katrina: No.
Jake: 那
Jake: Then...
Katrina:  但是我已经收拾干净了
Katrina: But I've cleaned it up.
Jake: 好那就可以看是吧
Jake: Alright, so we can check it out, right?
Jake: 还可以看
Jake: We can still see it.
Jake: 那什么时候能出完全品
Jake: When can it be fully completed?
Tasha: 不行
Tasha: No way.
Jake: 完全品
Jake: Fully completed.
Jake: 完全的屋子
Jake: The whole room is complete.
Katrina:  今天晚上就行呀
Katrina: It can be done tonight.
Jake: 完整状态
Jake: In complete condition.
Katrina:  因为我还有一个风铃跟一个贴墙上的没有弄好
Katrina: Because I still have a wind chime and a wall sticker that aren't done yet.
Lucia: 对 但是上去之前我还是要把那个东西粘一下
Lucia: Right, but before we go up, I still need to stick that thing.
Jake: 今晚完整状态
Jake: Tonight, in complete condition.
其他人：不然它会掉
Others: Or else it will fall.
Katrina:  因为今天早上弄压花去了
Katrina: Because this morning I was doing pressed flowers.
其他人：可以 哦压花
Others: Oh, pressed flowers.
其他人：对对对你们去别的房间的时候
Others: Yeah, yeah, when you guys went to the other room.
其他人：c我就溜进去整理我的
Others: I sneaked in and tidied up mine.
Alice: 确实 应该 驴打滚的亲戚
Alice: Indeed, it should be like a donkey roll's relative.
其他人： 对就是他这里还有两条腿
Others: Yeah, like it still has two legs here.
Shure:  是不是需要下去的
Shure: Does it need to go down?
Katrina:  打孔器的
Katrina: For the hole puncher.
Jake: 一个奔跑的 水母
Jake: A running jellyfish.
刘婷: 理论上说应该够了
Liu Ting: Theoretically, it should be enough.
刘婷: 就是完全的造型应该这样中间会有坠下来
Liu Ting: The complete shape should have something hanging in the middle.
Katrina:  他说他说这个东西要紧一点
Katrina: He said this thing needs to be tighter.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
其他人：但这个有点小
Others: But this is a bit small.
其他人：不太好做
Others: It's not easy to do.
Jake:没关系个
Jake: It's okay.
其他人：  估计现在就能吃了
Others: I guess we can eat now.
Alice: 这是熟的 蒸过的
Alice: This is cooked, it's been steamed.
Alice: 怎么我还能毒死你啊毒死你也不会在这哎
Alice: How could I poison you? If I poisoned you, you wouldn't be here.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahaha.
其他人：好上午搞了9个坐位
Others: This morning, we set up nine seats.
Jake: 行行行
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Shure: 现在不是6个吗
Shure: Aren't there six now?
其他人：啊6个加3个垫子加一个多余的桌子
Others: Yeah, six plus three cushions plus an extra table.
Alice: 哈哈哈这
Alice: Hahaha, this.
其他人：啊这些凳子可以给它搬上去
Others: Yeah, these stools can be moved up.
Jake: 这是这是这是多少
Jake: This is, this is how many?
其他人：（歌声）你做了什么
Others: (Singing) What did you do?
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Jake: 这小这这小马
Jake: This little, this little horse.
Jake: 可以安上去么
Jake: Can it be installed?
Shure:  也可以VVVIP
Shure: It can also be VVVVIP.
Jake: 好那就算了
Jake: Alright, then forget it.
Jake: 太重了是吧
Jake: Too heavy, right?
Shure:  你就是night vip
Shure: You're just a night VIP.
Jake: 牛批哎呀
Jake: Awesome, wow.
Shure:  ego night好吧
Shure: Ego night, okay?
其他人：他是Ego house
Others: He's from Ego House.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Jake: 剪映
Jake: Jianying
Jake: 剪映真尼玛好用
Jake: Jianying is really damn useful.
其他人：这首歌叫什么名字
Others: What's the name of this song?
Jake:哼you  life
Jake: Hum you life.
其他人：哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahahaha
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe
其他人： 你醒了
Others: You're awake.
其他人：哈哈
Others: Haha
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
其他人：你就喜欢玩这种逆天的是吗
Others: You just like to play these outrageous things, huh?
其他人:  我先看一下
Jake: 没有必要看
Jake: No need to watch.
其他人:  看一下
Jake: 你要看啥呀
Jake: What do you want to watch?
其他人:  看一眼都是什么环境
其他人:  OK  OK  OK      K K   K   K   没啦？
Jake:  对
其他人:  那为什么是奥克神
Jake:  因为
Jake: Because
其他人:  CTION
Jake:  开麦
Jake: Turn on the mic.
Jake:  他们要卖东西
Jake: They're selling stuff.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 不是你
Jake: It's not you.
Jake: 你看这个头像看
Jake: Look at this profile picture.
Jake: 明显不是你
Jake: It's obviously not you.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:ego nice是
Jake: Ego nice is
其他人： ego house
Others: Ego House.
Jake:我操
Jake: Damn.
Jake:行吧
Jake: Fine.
其他人：骑士
Others: Knight.
其他人：建议再给我发一把egos  w
Others: Suggest sending me another egos w.
Jake:那你是爷   呵呵呵
Jake: Then you're the boss. Hehehe
Jake: 你自己做一个
Jake: Make one yourself.
其他人：I 'M JACK  JACKQUEEN
Others: I’m Jack, Jackqueen.
Jake: 这个字有点太往下了
Jake: This text is a bit too low.
其他人：这主是AI生成吗
Others: Is this AI generated?
Jake:恩
Jake: Yeah.
其他人：别说还挺好
Others: It's actually pretty good.
Jake:确定
Jake: Confirmed.
Lucia: 哈喽哈喽哈喽
Lucia: Hello, hello, hello!
Jake:我不知道
Jake: I don't know.
其他人：虽然 已经有视频了
Others: Although there's already a video.
其他人：你的已经过了
Others: Yours is already done.
Jake: 对 你这已经上去了
Jake: Yeah, yours is already up.
Jake: 没关系你你先对
Jake: It's okay, you go ahead.
Jake: 保持一点神秘感
Jake: Keep a bit of mystery.
Jake: 因为你也不知道拍成什么样
Jake: Because you don't know how it turned out.
Jake: 我也
Jake: I also...
Jake: 我在昨天之前也不知道拍成什么样
Jake: I didn't know how it turned out until yesterday.
Jake: 咱整点正常的
Jake: Let's do something normal.
Jake: 哎呦我靠啥玩意
Jake: Oh my, what is this?
Jake:他咋还不上来他们
Jake: Why aren't they coming up?
Jake: 干哈呢
Jake: What are they doing?
其他人：在烤蛋挞
Others: Baking egg tarts.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
其他人：哎所以auction到底是什么
Others: Hey, so what exactly is an auction?
Jake: 拍卖拍卖
Jake: Auction, auction.
其他人：拍卖
Others: Auction.
Jake: 拍卖竞价拍卖
Jake: Bidding, auction.
其他人：OK 这么高级不认识
Others: Okay, so fancy, didn't recognize it.
Jake: 要帮忙吗
Jake: Need help?
Katrina:  这个怎么打孔器
Katrina: How does this puncher work?
Katrina:  不应该感觉这薄薄的一层
Katrina: Isn't it supposed to be just a thin layer?
Katrina:  很容易按下去吗
Katrina: Shouldn't it be easy to press down?
Jake: 就这么搞是吧
Jake: Just do it like this, right?
Shure:  按住是吗
Shure: Hold it down, right?
Jake: 要什么样的
Jake: What kind do you need?
Katrina:  就一个孔然后把这插进去
Katrina: Just one hole, then insert this.
Jake: 总之他应该是通的吗
Jake: So, it should go through, right?
Jake: 是通的
Jake: It goes through.
其他人：这是什么压花吗
Others: What is this, embossing?
Katrina:  嗯嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm.
Katrina:  你再打一个试试
Katrina: Try making another hole.
Jake:好 我再打一个
Jake: Okay, I'll make another one.
Jake: 我感觉他刚是没对准
Jake: I think it wasn't aligned properly before.
Jake: 刚刚没有咔一下
Jake: It didn't click before.
Jake: 哎这个到位啊
Jake: Hey, this one's perfect.
Katrina:  那就是我劲太小了
Jake: 光没对准
Jake: The light isn't aligned.
其他人：喂喂
Others: Hello, hello.
Jake: 那能调能调
Jake: It can be adjusted, it can be adjusted.
其他人:testing  testing
Others: Testing, testing.
其他人：哎这是这是 修硕的啊
Others: Hey, this is Shure's.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
其他人：所以所以你是干嘛 ，你放到他电脑里 他电脑离在后面
Others: So, so what are you doing? You put it on his computer, his computer is at the back.
Jake:对啊对啊
Jake:你好
Jake: Hello.
其他人：今天晚上要不要来一首普通 朋友
Others: Do you want to play "Ordinary Friends" tonight?
Katrina:   我那朋友也会弹你们一起吧
Katrina: My friend can play it too, you guys can do it together.
其他人：好普通 朋友
Others: Okay, "Ordinary Friends".
Jake:唉呀
Jake: Oh no.
Jake: 你们谁想打孔
Jake: Does anyone want to punch holes?
Jake: 打孔
Jake: Punch holes.
Katrina:  帮我打孔打个孔吧我摁不动
Katrina: Help me punch a hole, I can't press it down.
Jake: 打个孔
Jake: Punch a hole.
Jake: 就在这打孔
Jake: Just punch here.
Katrina:  就握一下就行了
Katrina: Just squeeze it, that's all.
Katrina:  但是我的力气太小
Katrina: But I'm not strong enough.
Jake: 就这样看啊
Jake: Like this, see?
Jake: 然后在一个合适的位置
Jake: Then at a suitable position.
其他人：OK
Others: OK.
Jake:我考
Jake: Oh my god.
其他人：唉呀我考
Others: Oh my god.
Katrina:  按下去
Katrina: Press it down.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
其他人：哇挺好看的
Others: Wow, it looks pretty good.
Jake: 就这么还行吧
Jake: It's okay like this, right?
Katrina:  还行吧
Katrina: It's okay.
其他人：挺好看挺好看
Others: It looks pretty good, pretty good.
Jake: 我考啥玩意
Jake: What the heck is this?
其他人：所以你们每个人都有一幅吗
Others: So does everyone have one?
Katrina:  没有就我做
Katrina: No, just me.
Katrina:  他们忙自己的东西
Katrina: They're busy with their own stuff.
Jake: 他这个有点
Jake: This one is kind of...
其他人：这么难打吧
Others: Is it that hard to punch?
Jake: 没有没有没有
Jake: No, no, no.
Jake: 他这样这样这样
Jake: Like this, like this, like this.
Jake: 就是它得是它得有一个支点比较好打
Jake: It needs a pivot point, it's easier to punch.
其他人：给我一个支点我可以撬动地球
Other people: Give me a lever long enough and I can move the Earth.
Katrina:  是的高中你们有打过那个讲义没
Katrina: Yeah, did you guys ever use those handouts in high school?
Katrina:  也是用打孔器打的
Katrina: We used a hole puncher too.
Jake: 这个可以穿
Jake: This can go through.
Lucia: 打一个环可以穿
Lucia: Punch a ring and it can go through.
其他人：别打我手上
Other people: Don't hit my hand.
其他人：确定是这么按的吗
Other people: Are you sure you press it like this?
Jake:这个打孔 器在离谱了
Jake: This hole puncher is ridiculous.
Jake: 因为他这个很小
Jake: Because it's so small.
其他人：对对对齐对齐
Other people: Yes, yes, align it.
其他人：这就好看了
Other people: This looks good now.
Jake:这个对啊
Jake: Exactly.
Shure:  所以我
Shure: So I...
Jake: 就是它这个过道很窄就是你只能这么
Jake: It's just that this passage is so narrow, you can only...
Alice: 他那个不值200吗
Alice: Isn't it worth 200?
Jake: 他要大一点
Jake: It needs to be a bit bigger.
Jake: 各位手太大了这手
Jake: Everyone's hands are too big.
Jake: 啊你可能还不够小
Jake: Oh, maybe it's still not small enough.
Alice: 没关系
Alice: It's okay.
Jake: 使不上劲
Jake: Not enough strength.
Jake: 你卡
Jake: You stuck?
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Yes.
Katrina:  我也感觉使不上劲这
Katrina: I feel like I can't use enough strength either.
Jake: 怎么样啊
Jake: How is it?
Jake: 哇哦
Jake: Wow.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Jake: 我来切
Jake: Let me cut it.
Jake: 哈哈不理我
Jake: Haha, ignoring me.
Katrina:  这是你切的吗
Katrina: Did you cut this?
Jake: 对对对 算了算了算了算了
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, never mind, never mind.
Alice: 你知道怎么挂吗
Alice: Do you know how to hang it?
Alice: 那你就这么自信的走过去
Alice: Then you confidently walk over.
Alice: 你再给我装饰
Alice: And decorate it for me.
Alice: 破坏了 美景破坏了
Alice: You ruined the scenery, ruined it.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 咱还是不毁了
Jake: Let's not ruin it.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 哈喽
Jake: Hello.
Jake:哈喽
Jake:你好
Jake: Hello
Katrina:  压干水分了
Katrina: Squeezed out all the water.
Jake:很难
Jake: It's really hard.
其他人：这玩意真的很难
Others: This thing is really hard.
Jake: 这反人类设计
Jake: This design is inhumane.
其他人：确实
Others: Indeed.
Jake: 就是应该是这么一下
Jake: It should be like this.
其他人：我觉得不如拿剪刀直接剪一下
Others: I think we should just use scissors and cut it.
其他人：这个这个这个
Others: This, this, this.
Jake:我来我来我来
Jake: Let me, let me, let me.
其他人：这样能凑合凑合
Others: That should do the job.
Jake: 来给我一个
Jake: Give me one.
Katrina:  哈哈哈也行
Katrina: Hahaha, that works too.
Katrina:  只要他没那个啥的
Katrina: As long as he doesn't...
其他人： 妈的像极了那天咱俩铺草丛
Others: Damn, reminds me of when we laid the grass.
其他人： 然后转 然后就是弄完你就转
Others: Then you turn, and after you're done, you turn.
Jake: 行吧 哦
Jake: Alright, oh.
Jake: 转是吧
Jake: Turn, right?
其他人：但是转他还不太好
Others: But turning is still tricky.
Jake: 但是我这个是不是已经
Jake: But is mine already...
其他人：没有没有想多了
Others: No, no, you're overthinking.
Jake: 自信了自信了
Jake: Got confident, got confident.
其他人：哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha.
其他人：拿住
Others: Hold it.
Jack:  你别把她花拽坏啊
Jack: Don't break her flower.
其他人：那不会
Others: That won't happen.
Jake: 我们只旋转
Jake: We're just rotating.
其他人：唉唉可以了
Others: Hey, hey, that's good enough.
Lucia: 直博
Lucia: Direct PhD.
Jake: 我们只旋转
Jake: We're just rotating.
Katrina:  这样的话我
Katrina: In that case, I...
Jake:好了好了   哎不行少行
Jake: Alright, alright, no, not enough.
Jake: 这个破坏有点大这个
Jake: This damage is a bit much.
其他人：啊你这个已经装 不进去了
Others: Ah, this one can't fit anymore.
其他人：只能有一个孔然后那个烂了
Others: Only one hole, and that one is ruined.
Jake: 你们这么压是有用的吗
Jake: Is it useful to press it like this?
其他人：烂了这个不太好
Others: It's ruined, this is not good.
其他人：这个是吗
Others: Is this it?
Katrina:  就是
Katrina: Exactly.
Katrina: 这能卖的出去吗
Katrina: Can this be sold?
Jake:呵
Jake: Ha
Katrina:  就是拍卖呀
Katrina: It's an auction
Katrina:  大家不是每个人都做的东西吗
Katrina: Isn't everyone doing it?
Katrina:  他们卖小狗啊
Katrina: They're selling puppies
其他人：卖小狗，哦 那个小狗是卖的啊
Others: Selling puppies, oh so those puppies are for sale?
Katrina:  就是但是总归和环保相关就行
Katrina: Yes, but it just needs to be related to environmental protection
Katrina:  这是哪一个地方
Katrina: Where is this place?
其他人：ego 币
Others: ego currency
Jake: 哎这么不值钱呢
Jake: Why is it so worthless?
其他人：everybody  has    ego
Others: everybody has ego
Jake: 搞不懂一点你来把呵呵呵
Jake: I don't get it, you handle it, haha
其他人：我来那我来
Others: I'll do it, let me do it
Jake: 我放弃了
Jake: I give up
其他人：你怎么就放弃了
Others: Why are you giving up?
Jake: 我不请
Jake: I won't do it
其他人：啊 欧
Others: Ah oh
其他人：为什么我考
Others: Why did I fail?
其他人：感觉受力不均匀
Others: It feels uneven
其他人：咱们一天
Others: One day
其他人：所有脏的话 只要有个孔就可以
Others: Any dirty words, as long as there's a hole, it's okay
其他人：你看着这个用着挺顺手为什么实际上那么菜呢
Others: It looks handy, but why is it so bad in practice?
Jake: 他就是
Jake: It's just
Jake: 他就是不称职
Jake: It's just incompetent
Katrina:  是不是打纸会好一点打这种塑料
Katrina: Would it be better to punch paper instead of plastic?
Jake: 他就是
Jake: It's just
Katrina:  你试一下
Katrina: Try it out
Katrina:  搞一个这个试一下看看
Katrina: Try this one out and see
Katrina:  是这个东西的问题
Katrina: Maybe it's the problem with this thing
其他人：这随便打
Others: Just punch it randomly
其他人：质量 不太好
Others: The quality isn't very good
其他人：哦我们可以结合一下用这个钉子来
Others: Oh, we can combine it with this nail
其他人：这我5分钟时间就发现了
Others: I found this out in 5 minutes
其他人：是因为我没打好
Others: It's because I didn't punch it well
其他人：这不是我们5分钟之前的事情吗
Others: Wasn't this something we figured out 5 minutes ago?
其他人：我        一下 发现还是最好用
Others: I found out it's still the best to use
其他人：对对它这个不均匀受力不均匀不知道为什么
Others: Yeah, it's uneven, don't know why
Alice: 你现在怎么变内向了
Alice: Why are you so introverted now?
Alice: 刘婷你不是挺爱说话的吗
Alice: Liu Ting, weren't you very talkative?
Jake: 我去
Jake: Oh my gosh
Jake:我去
Jake: 这个留着让大伙一起挤
Jake: We'll keep this for everyone to squeeze.
Jake: 就是这个奶油的
Jake: This cream, I mean.
Jake: 奶油大伙可以自己挤
Jake: Everyone can squeeze the cream themselves.
Tasha: 什么奶油
Tasha: What cream?
Jake:这个上面会有奶油
Jake: There will be cream on top.
Tasha: 还没挤还没打人家说蛋挞里一起打
Tasha: Haven't squeezed it yet, haven't mixed it, they said to mix it in with the egg tarts.
Alice: 怎么内向
Alice: Why so shy?
Alice: 不唱了 怎么这么摇滚
Alice: Not singing anymore? Why so rock and roll?
Shure:  怎么这么摇滚
Shure: Why so rock and roll?
Alice: 我记得你唱歌挺好听的呀
Alice: I remember you sing pretty well.
Jake: 你干嘛呢
Jake: What are you doing?
Jake: 呵呵呵呆
Jake: Haha, just dazing off?
Jake: 没有这么火
Jake: Not that popular.
Lucia: 我在等我的小伙伴来
Lucia: I'm waiting for my friend to come.
Lucia: 他应该一会就到了
Lucia: He should be here soon.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 电足是吗
Jake: Is the power enough?
Jake: 电是开着的
Jake: The power is on.
Lucia: 很难说它足不足
Lucia: Hard to say if it's enough.
Lucia: 因为我衣服上没口袋
Lucia: Because my clothes don't have pockets.
Lucia: 所以我刚站着的时候就把它取下来了
Lucia: So I took it off when I was standing.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 有必要一会再连一下
Lucia: Maybe we should connect it again later.
Jake: 这个充电宝是你的吗这是谁的
Jake: Is this power bank yours? Whose is it?
Jake: OK行
Jake: OK, fine.
Jake: 好看
Jake: Looks good.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Lucia: 理论上他应该比较大一点
Lucia: Theoretically, it should be bigger.
Lucia: 这太小我觉得我手都塞不进去
Lucia: This is too small, I don't think my hand can fit in.
Lucia: 而且也没有那啥
Lucia: And it doesn't have that thing.
Lucia: 而且就这个这个这个这个脚
Lucia: And this, this, this foot thing.
其他人：这有没有矿泉水啊
Others: Is there any mineral water here?
Jake:没有买一点你再买一点
Jake: No, buy some, you go buy some more.
Katrina:  现在就
Katrina: Right now?
Lucia: 而且不好固定
Lucia: And it's hard to secure.
Jake: 要帮忙吗
Jake: Need help?
Jake: 我靠这怎么这个样子
Jake: Wow, why is it like this?
Alice: 筛一锅我磕磕
Alice: Sift a pot, I'll crack it.
Tasha: 铺层
Tasha: Lay a layer.
Tasha: 有纸吗
Tasha: Is there any paper?
Tasha: 有纸
Alice: 婷
Alice: Ting
Tasha: 这两个都铺一下
Tasha: Lay these two out.
Alice: give me 有纸
Alice: Give me the paper.
Shure:  咦什么咦
Shure: Huh? What huh?
Alice: 我说
Alice: I said...
Alice: 我说你你低智
Alice: I said you're an idiot.
Jake: 修硕你来执行任务吧
Jake: Shure, you handle the task.
Jake: 一些采购任务
Jake: Some procurement tasks.
Jake: 买来水然后一个大披萨
Jake: Get some water and a large pizza.
Jake: 我要大披萨
Jake: I want a large pizza.
Jake: 来把修硕给弄上了
Jake: Come on, get Shure involved.
Jake: 修硕
Jake: Shure!
Alice: 我跟姐妹待这长时间
Alice: I've been with my sisters for a long time.
Jake: 你好
Jake: Hello.
Jake: 你来指导一下
Jake: You come and guide us.
Jake: 买点啥今天我们吃的那个东西
Jake: What should we buy for today's meal?
Shure:  谢老板
Shure: Thanks, boss.
Jake: 没有没有就准备好就行 下个单
Jake: No problem, just get it ready. Place the order.
Jake: 下个单到时候一见
Jake: Place the order, and we'll see it when it arrives.
Shure:  你搜搜有没有蘸点披萨
Shure: Can you check if there's any dipping sauce for the pizza?
Alice: 虽然有这个
Alice: Although there's this...
Alice: 但我没看见
Alice: I didn't see it.
Alice: 给你表演一个丝滑
Alice: Let me show you something smooth.
Alice: 撕这个好吗
Alice: Tear this, alright?
Alice: 如果不丝滑就是愿意看
Alice: If it's not smooth, just enjoy watching.
Alice: 你影响了观测
Alice: You're affecting the observation.
Jake: Lucia他有人
Jake: Lucia, someone is here.
Jake: 准备来
Jake: Get ready.
Jake: 一层
Jake: First floor.
Katrina:  你来
Katrina: You go.
Jake: 一层要收拾就
Jake: Clean up the first floor.
Jake: Lucia有个同学
Jake: Lucia, a classmate is here.
Jake: Lucia是去接了吗
Jake: Lucia, did you go pick them up?
Jake: 是的哦那很好啊
Jake: Yes, that's great.
Jake: 对就接55
Jake: Yeah, just pick them up and they'll be here soon.
Jake: 就接一下就到就好了
Jake: Get them seated, okay?
Jake: 让他们坐好吧要不
Jake: Make sure they're seated properly.
Katrina:  坐好啊
Katrina: Sit properly.
Jake: 对 坐到二楼坐好
Jake: Yes, sit on the second floor.
Jake: 不行得再剪点
Jake: No, we need to cut a bit more.
Lucia: 是长这样吗
Lucia: Is it supposed to look like this?
Lucia: 他虽然还在转
Lucia: Even though it's still spinning
Jake:恩  这儿了这儿了
Jake: Yeah, here, right here.
Jake: 那紫藤让他们到二楼坐好吧
Jake: Then Violet, have them sit on the second floor.
Jake: 然后一楼
Jake: And the first floor
Jake: 嗯对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Lucia: 好我今天也穿拖鞋出来了
Lucia: Okay, I wore slippers out today too.
Lucia: 特长的这个
Lucia: These really long ones.
Alice: 你慎言我跟你说
Alice: Be careful with what you say, I'm telling you.
Alice: 那人家设计的那啥
Alice: The designs of those things
Alice: 你怎么老干那种事啊
Alice: Why do you always do that kind of stuff?
Jake: 鞋挺大
Jake: The shoes are pretty big.
Lucia: 你穿拖鞋出来的时候
Lucia: When you wear slippers out
Lucia: 不会有它要掉的感觉么
Lucia: Don't you feel like they're about to fall off?
Jake: 没有我因为穿了好多年了 对
Jake: No, because I've worn them for many years. Yeah.
Jake: 又特别熟练
Jake: I'm very skilled at it.
Jake: 特别懂衣服
Jake: I really know clothes.
Jake: 穿拖鞋打篮球
Jake: Playing basketball in slippers.
Jake: 踢足球
Jake: Playing soccer.
Lucia:啊 你再说一遍
Lucia: Ah, say that again.
Jake: 真的真的
Jake: Really, really.
Lucia:  拖鞋的一百种打开方式
Lucia: A hundred ways to use slippers.
Jake:用拖鞋打篮球命中率会高一些
Jake: Using slippers to play basketball increases accuracy.
Lucia: 真的假的哦
Lucia: Really?
Lucia: 不是你看我马上就把鞋甩掉了
Lucia: No, look, I'd just kick my shoes off right away.
Jake: 这个拖鞋可能还是 不太合脚
Jake: 定制一个拖鞋
Jake: Custom-made slippers.
Lucia: 所以您拖鞋是定制的吗
Lucia: So, are your slippers custom-made?
Jake: 不是就是众多
Jake: No, they're just among many.
Jake: 哈喽哈喽哈喽哈喽哈喽
Jake: Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello.
Lucia: 我们往那边走
Lucia: Let's walk over there.
Jake:好好对
Jake: Okay, okay, right.
Lucia: 现在就过去是吧
Lucia: We're heading over now, right?
Lucia: 靖康你来解释一下
Lucia: Jingkang, can you explain this?
Jake: 这个是什么中国
Jake: What's this, China...
Jake: 呃叫什么
Jake: Uh, what's it called...
Jake: 村改别墅的发源地
Jake: The origin of village-to-villa transformation.
Jake: 哎对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Jake: 然后这里面都
Jake: And then inside here...
Jake: 大概是自建的别墅
Jake: It's basically all self-built villas.
Jake: 这一片 太大了
Jake: This area is huge.
Jake: 虽然很村
Jake: Even though it's very rural,
Jake: 但是外卖都能点了 就能活了
Jake: you can still order delivery and live comfortably.
Jake: 自己会做很多东西
Jake: You can make a lot of things yourself.
Jake: 对我们整个
Jake: For our entire...
Jake: 在这儿整 七天
Jake: We've been here for seven days.
Jake: 就为了迎接你们哈哈哈
Jake: Just to welcome you all, haha.
Lucia: 我们其实准备了水
Lucia: Actually, we prepared water.
Shure:  饿了吗
Shure: Hungry?
Lucia: 你还自己买了水
Lucia: And you even bought water yourself.
Lucia: 就是会有饮料和甜点
Lucia: There will be drinks and desserts.
Lucia: 甜点正在做
Lucia: The desserts are being made.
Jake: 你打车来的是
Jake: Did you take a taxi here?
Jake: 你打多久的车过来的
Jake: How long did it take?
Jake: 地铁啊OK
Jake: Subway? OK.
Lucia: 对我跟她说的是
Lucia: Yes, I told her...
Lucia: 在化妆站 附近
Lucia: near the makeup station.
Lucia: 所以就得
Lucia: So...
Alice: 顾头不顾腚刘婷
Alice: Focusing on the head and not the bottom, Liu Ting.
Lucia: 所以远吗其实
Lucia: So, is it far actually?
Lucia: 好像
Lucia: Seems like...
Alice: 刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting.
Lucia: 反正我听同学说好像不太远的样子
Lucia: Anyway, my classmates said it doesn't seem too far.
Jake: 今天一号线人多吗
Jake: Was Line 1 crowded today?
其他人：主要是中间那个车不到这只到
Jake:哦OK
Jake: Oh, OK.
Lucia: 如果你想其实可以跟我们一块做
Alice: 因为
Lucia: 种种原因
Lucia: For various reasons...
Lucia: 本来计划
Lucia: The original plan...
Lucia: 在就是大家的小伙伴到之前就做好
Lucia: Was to finish before everyone's friends arrived.
Lucia: 但实际上现在
Lucia: But actually now...
Lucia: 现在正在做
Lucia: We're still making it.
Jake: 我们上二楼然后就开始吧
Jake: Let's go to the second floor and start.
Lucia: 啊直接上二楼吗
Lucia: Oh, straight to the second floor?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 或者你可以带着这个上二楼做
Jake: Or you can take this to the second floor to work.
Katrina:  哈喽哈喽
Katrina: Hello, hello
Jake: 哈喽哈喽
Jake: Hello, hello
Jake: 那就齐了
Jake: Now we're all here
Katrina:  上楼吧
Katrina: Let's go upstairs
Jake: 上楼吧
Jake: Let's go upstairs
Katrina:  迅速开始
Katrina: Let's start quickly
Katrina:  迟到43分钟
Katrina: We're 43 minutes late
Alice: 因为你朋友来吗
Alice: Because your friend came?
Lucia: 我在找个充电宝把我的那个啥哎
Lucia: I was looking for a power bank to charge my... hey
Jake: 来来来
Jake: Come, come, come
Jake: 请
Jake: Please
其他人：你要你要从那儿进来
Others: You need to come in from there
Jake: 啊好
Jake: Ah, okay
Jake: 你当DJ是吧
Jake: You're the DJ, right?
Jake: 等大家
Jake: Wait for everyone
Lucia: 然后我再下来帮大家做甜品
Lucia: Then I'll come down and help make desserts
Jake: 等人齐了吧
Jake: Wait until everyone's here
其他人：先给你预热排练一遍
Others: Let's warm up and rehearse once
Jake: 排练一遍啊
其他人：now let's welcome today
Others: Now let's welcome today
其他人：杨靖康
Others: Yang Jingkang
其他人：耶
Others: Yay
其他人：对就UFC那种
Others: Like UFC, right
Jake: 一一击掌是吧
Jake: A high-five, right?
其他人：对击掌
Others: Yeah, a high-five
Jake:耶耶耶
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah
Alice: 这个菱形
Alice: This diamond shape
Lucia: 既然大家都到的差不多了
Lucia: Since almost everyone is here
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay
其他人：就是学术访问
Others: It's an academic visit
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Jake: 一个我们赶不上的会议
Jake: A meeting we can't catch up with
Jake: 呵呵呵
Jake: Haha
Jake: 请进
Jake: Come in
Jake: 欢迎
Jake: Welcome
Jake: 欢迎啊呵呵呵
Jake: Welcome, haha
其他人：马斯克
Others: Musk
Jake:怎么了
Jake: What's up?
Alice: 少爷嘛
Alice: The young master
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay
Jake: 估计他们想要拍了
Jake: I guess they want to start filming.
Jake: 但是
Jake: But
Jake: 什么充电宝
Jake: What power bank?
Jake:那就拿点呗
Jake: Then just take some.
Lucia: 我也需要充电宝
Lucia: I need a power bank too.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 有有有
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Jake: 有一些要小心使用的
Jake: There are some that need to be used carefully.
Jake: 充电宝就是它得
Jake: The power bank, it has to
Jake: 它在一直在闪 它才充电
Jake: It has to keep flashing to charge.
Jake: 所以要比较小心
Jake: So be careful.
Jake: 就不像这么明显
Jake: It's not that obvious.
Katrina:  上吧
Katrina: Let's go.
Katrina:  开始了得
Katrina: It's starting.
Jake: 好那我们这边就
Jake: Alright, then we'll
Jake: 算了可以开始
Jake: I guess we can start.
Alice: 还还需要
Alice: Still need
Jake: 还需要
Jake: Still need
Alice: 奶油挤
Alice: Whipped cream.
Jake: 挤奶油要不就
Jake: Whipped cream, or
Jake: 挤奶油大概要多久啊
Jake: How long does it take to whip cream?
Jake: 还是说可以把它冻起来
Jake: Or can we just freeze it?
Alice: 什么冻起来
Alice: Freeze what?
Jake: 就放冰箱冻起来给他们一起挤
Jake: Just put it in the fridge and freeze it, then whip it together.
Jake: 我们得
Jake: We have to
Jake: 那我们如果在这开始
Jake: If we start here
Jake: 那我们可能也不能 不能开始
Jake: Then we might not be able to start.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 所以我们
Jake: So we
Shure:  let's
Shure: Let's
Katrina:  谁主持人你
Katrina: Who's the host, you?
Jake: : 三三点五十
Jake: At 3:50
Jake: 因为下面的甜点还在准备
Jake: Because the desserts are still being prepared.
Jake: 所以还有点奶油要挤
Jake: So there's still some cream to whip.
Lucia: 需要我去celebrate一下吗
Lucia: Do you need me to celebrate a bit?
Shure:  呃对可以加完速加个5分钟的速
Shure: Uh, yeah, you can speed up for 5 minutes.
Jake: 我们就开始4点吧
Jake: Let's start at 4 o'clock.
Jake: 就这么4点吧
Jake: Alright, 4 o'clock then.
Jake: 好 4点开始
Jake: Okay, start at 4.
Jake: 那你们开个场吧
Jake: You guys start.
Jake: 你要不就
Jake: If you could just...
Alice: 你的朋友到了吗
Alice: Has your friend arrived?
Jake: 你的music开场了
Jake: Your music is starting.
Katrina:  唱首歌吧
Katrina: Sing a song!
Jake:剪刀
Jake: Scissors.
Jake: 可能要帮师傅翻一下
Jake: We might need to help the master translate.
Alice: 切一下切成两半吗
Alice: Should we cut it in half?
Alice: 有的要切对半
Alice: Some need to be cut in half.
Alice: 我们的案板呢
Alice: Where's our cutting board?
Lucia: 这个吗
Lucia: This one?
Alice: 对
Alice: Yes.
Alice: : 干净的吗
Alice: Is it clean?
Lucia: 啊小心
Lucia: Oh, careful.
Lucia: 应该或者
Lucia: Maybe or...
Lucia: 大概也许是涮一下吧
Lucia: Probably just rinse it a bit.
Alice: 涮一下吧
Alice: Just rinse it.
Lucia: 我去把那个
Lucia: I'll go get that.
Lucia: 翻好了OK
Lucia: Flipped it, OK.
Tasha: 都把这个细壳克去掉
Tasha: Remove all these thin shells.
Lucia: 抓不住
Lucia: Can't get a grip.
Jake: 我怎么叠了一层下去
Jake: Why did I fold it down a layer?
Lucia: 不行我完全抓不住它
Lucia: No, I can't get a grip at all.
Lucia: 拆半天光拆下来一个
Lucia: Took so long just to get one off.
Jake:欧欧欧
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Shure:  哦对
Shure: Oh, right.
Jake: 暖起来
Jake: Warm it up.
Shure:  好的好的
Shure: Okay, okay.
Jake: 专业暖场
Jake: Professional warm-up.
Shure:  是不是大家这个场子不够不够
Shure: Is it that everyone's just not warmed up enough?
Shure:  不够热那要不把空调调高两度吧
Shure: It's not warm enough, should we turn up the AC by two degrees?
Jake:好你们挤完就OK
Jake: Alright, you're done squeezing, that's okay.
Jake: 拿到
Jake: Got it.
Shure:  这就不用好了
Shure: No need for this.
Jake: 拿到哪去
Jake: Where to take it?
Lucia: 这个那个哪个
Lucia: This one, that one, which one?
Lucia: 上面的那个吗
Lucia: The one on top?
Jake:这个我们是在这儿摆盘是吗
Jake: Are we plating it here?
Lucia: 那边没有电子产品吗
Lucia: No electronic devices over there?
Jake:那边没有
Jake: None over there.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 你们你们要不暖场
Jake: You guys, why don't you warm up the room?
Jake: 要不下来干活
Jake: Or come down and work.
Jake: 不能坐着知道不
Jake: You can't just sit there, you know that, right?
Jake: 所谓剧组成员
Jake: That's what being part of the crew means.
Alice: 咋了
Alice: What's up?
Jake: 把这个收拾
Jake: Clean this up.
Lucia: 暖不了一点
Lucia: Can't warm up a bit.
Jake: 收拾收拾把这个收掉
Jake: Clean up, clean this up.
Jake:现马上就要蒸呗
Jake: We're about to steam it now.
Tasha: 不这两个就只有这个小房子不要
Tasha: No, just these two, not this little house.
Jake: 刘帅呢
Jake: Where's Choiszt?
Jake: 董叉叉呢
Jake: Where's Jack?
Jake:  干嘛呢
Jake: What are they doing?
Jake: 哈哈 他们他们在暖吗
Jake: Haha, are they warming up?
Katrina:  有品
Katrina: Stylish.
Jake:呵maybe
Jake: Haha, maybe.
Shure: 这个要吗
Shure: Do you need this?
Alice: 不要
Alice: No.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Lucia: 怒偷一本武林秘籍
Lucia: Steal a martial arts manual.
Jake: 唉我去放在这边擦干的是不
Jake: Hey, I was going to put it here to dry, right?
Lucia: 小心那地方刚擦干
Lucia: Be careful, that spot was just dried.
Lucia: 要不还是换个地方放因为这是纸容易受潮
Lucia: Maybe put it somewhere else because this is paper and it can get damp.
Alice: 是不是饮料洒了
Alice: Did someone spill a drink?
Alice: 怎么闻见一股果汁味呢
Alice: Why do I smell juice?
Lucia: 是
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 刚才有一瓶那个
Lucia: There was a bottle just now.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one.
Lucia: 这是谁的
Lucia: Whose is this?
Alice: 你咋不在上面呢
Alice: Why aren't you upstairs?
Alice: 那上面也有卫生间
Alice: There's a bathroom upstairs too.
其他人：上面也有
Others: There's one upstairs too.
Lucia: 没事你都下来了就去吧
Lucia: It's okay, now that you're down, just go.
Lucia: 刚讲ai line
Lucia: Just talked about AI line.
Jake: 还有啥这个要洗掉对吧
Jake: What else? This needs to be washed, right?
Jake: 这些都不要
Jake: We don't need any of these.
Jake: 为什么现在有手套了
Jake: Why are there gloves now?
Jake: 怎么
Jake: What's up?
Alice: 因为刚来的
Alice: They just arrived.
Alice: 这要不补一点
Alice: Should we add a bit more?
Jake: 这个要丢掉是吧
Jake: This needs to be thrown away, right?
Jake: 这个这个肯定是空的
Jake: This one is definitely empty.
Jake: 这些该放哪啊
Jake: Where should these go?
Tasha: 这这8个都放在这个托盘上
Tasha: These eight should go on this tray.
Tasha: 都放在那个小架子上
Tasha: Put them all on that small rack.
Alice: 那个架子脏脏的
Alice: That rack is dirty.
Jake: 这这这八个是吧
Jake: These eight, right?
Tasha: 那就放托盘上
Tasha: Then put them on the tray.
Jake: 架子脏脏的就垫一下吧
Jake: If the rack is dirty, just put something under it.
Alice: 托盘吧
Alice: The tray, then.
Jake: 这个这个纸
Jake: This paper...
Lucia: 纸在
Lucia: The paper is here.
Alice: 纸在这
Alice: The paper is here.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Katrina:  哇还有麦旋风吗
Katrina: Wow, is there still McFlurry?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Alice: 对你的麦旋风
Alice: Yes, your McFlurry.
Jake: 我买的麦旋风
Jake: I bought the McFlurry.
Tasha: 干嘛
Tasha: What's up?
Jake: 垫垫一下吗
Jake: Just put it under, right?
Katrina:  现在要拿上去吗
Katrina: Should we take it up now?
Katrina:  还是等会他们下来吃
Katrina: Or wait for them to come down and eat?
Tasha: 剪很窄就行了
Tasha: Just cut it narrow.
Alice: 等吧
Alice: Wait.
Jake: 这个放在这吧
Jake: Put this here.
Alice: 剪跟他 还有3分钟
Alice: Cut it, there's 3 minutes left.
Katrina:  还有3分钟
Katrina: 3 minutes left.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 剪刀
Lucia: Scissors.
Jake: 4点开始
Jake: Start at 4 o'clock.
Alice: 在那在那
Alice: Over there, over there.
Jake: 剪一下
Jake: Cut it.
Jake: 剪刀
Jake: Scissors.
Lucia: 这个地方可以直接撕
Lucia: You can tear this part directly.
Jake: 有点
Jake: A bit.
Lucia: 我来
Lucia: Let me do it.
Alice: 这个不好使
Alice: This one doesn't work well.
Lucia: 因为那个剪刀
Lucia: Because those scissors...
Lucia: 刚才好像不是用来剪快递的吗
Lucia: Weren't they used to cut packages earlier?
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 我已经用来剪它啊
Alice: 无所谓了
Jake: 没关系没关系没听见没听见
Lucia:  也没事
Jake: 没听见没听见
Lucia: 嗯确实
Lucia: 这里面有一个那个啥的印
Lucia: 那也够吧
Lucia: 那是沿着撕缝的
Jake: 我们这个摆在上面么
Katrina:  这是我的冰激凌
Jake: 海是摆在下面了
Tasha: 这条会不有点窄
Lucia: 好像还行 但是会长出来一点点
Alice: 剪了吧剪了
Alice: 你折一下然后我剪
Alice: 按照你的痕迹剪
Lucia: 它大概长出来这么多
Jake: 剪一下剪一下
Jake: 那底下呢
Jake: What about the bottom?
Alice: 底下呢 对啊
Alice: The bottom, yeah.
Lucia: 感觉这样也行
Lucia: I think this works too.
Alice: 你给我捏捏肩膀好吗
Alice: Can you massage my shoulders?
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Lucia: 现在应该差不多好
Lucia: It should be fine now.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay.
Lucia: 啊水来了
Lucia: Ah, the water's here.
Jake: 行
Jake: Okay.
Jake:来水
Jake: Here comes the water.
Jake: 我们上去喷喷水
Jake: Let's go spray some water.
Jake: 这个就往上面摆了
Jake: Just put this on top.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Lucia: 请大家先喝点矿泉水
Lucia: Everyone, please have some mineral water first.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Alice: 那个太长了
Alice: That one's too long.
Alice: 就光底下那个底就行了
Alice: Just the bottom part will do.
Lucia: 好好看啊
Lucia: It looks so good.
Lucia: 底下是不是还需要一条
Lucia: Do we need another one at the bottom?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 一会儿 我们端上去吗
Jake: Should we bring it up later?
Alice: 在上面还是在下边
Alice: Upstairs or downstairs?
Jake: 端上去吧下面
Jake: Bring it to the bottom.
Jake: 上面有地方放
Jake: There's space on the top.
Jake: 你干嘛呢
Jake: What are you doing?
Jake: 你你干嘛呢
Jake: Hey, what are you doing?
其他人：没事啊
Others: Nothing.
Jake: 你他妈怎么能怎么没事呢我操
Jake: How can you say it's nothing? Damn it! 社会问题
Jake:恩啊
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:那个
Jake: That...
Jake: 我们上面放甜品吧要不
Jake: Let's put the desserts on the top, okay?
其他人：好
Others: Sure.
Jake: 那片我们放甜品
Jake: We'll put the desserts there.
Jake: 不是你你自己会
Jake: Can't you do it yourself?
Jake: 卧槽
Jake: Damn it.
Shure:  什么情况
Shure: What's going on?
Jake: 你是客人是吧
Jake: Are you a guest?
Shure:  没有
Shure: No.
Shure: 这个也可以放里
Shure: This can go in here too.
Shure: 哦在这个地方呢
Shure: Oh, here it is.